tuesday edition p-f-t-o-t peter king
mike florio the draft is two days away
let's play a little quarterback
matchmaker let's try to figure out where
five of the biggest names at the
quarterback position heading into this
draft will land when it's time to start
calling them out and let's start with
joe burrow peter i'm convinced it's down
to the bengals or the dolphins and the
only way it's not going to be the
bengals is if the dolphins make the
bengals an offer they can't refuse an
offer they won't refuse because who
knows maybe the bengals won't realize
they have an offer they can't refuse but
after talking to burro yesterday i'd
refuse all offers i'd run to the podium
or wherever you have to run this year in
the virtual draft to get that name in do
you envision any possibility of the
dolphins making any type of a move or is
it borough to the bengals period
exclamation point
i think it's borough to the bengals mike
i mean you know human nature being what
it is will stephen ross
you know
say something that he hasn't said yet
which is chris greer you've got to trade
five ones for
joe burrow i i just don't think that's
going to happen because his head coach
doesn't want to do it and the general
manager doesn't want to do it joe
burrows going to the bengals
well that one's easy enough but there is
and i don't know it's it's a small small
chance but it would be stephen ross
commandeering the ship and telling his
coach in gm to get out of the way which
makes you wonder why do you even have a
coach in a gm if you're not going to let
the people that you've entrusted these
jobs to decide the future of the
franchise so i think it will be burrowed
to the bengals and i think he's going to
be very good now you need to have
blocking we talked earlier in the show
about how tim couch wasn't a bad
quarterback he just got killed in
cleveland hopefully they'll have
protection for joe burrow in cincinnati
the next name i want to go to is justin
herbert because i'm in the mindset that
he's going to get drafted before
tuatanga by load do you agree with that
and regardless where do you think
herbert ends up
i think herbert ends up with the
dolphins mike uh but
i'm in the 70 range on that i think it's
gonna happen
i'd put ten bucks in vegas on herbert to
the dolphins but i wouldn't put a
hundred
um
i think there's a lot of
uh there's a lot of question
about how good
justin herbert will be i mean opening
day
this year you know he's probably the
best guy in this draft okay i get it
but he because he's the healthiest he's
big strong-armed he runs well he's gonna
make plays in and out of the pocket i
get it
but you have to ask yourself does justin
herbert have the upside
of
say
and i'm not even gonna say mahomes or or
you know or or lamar jackson i'm gonna
say does he have the upside
of a very good nfl quarterback and so
that is what miami really has had to
decide obviously they've made their
decision by now i think they're going to
go with him but we'll see
and then you've got the wild card of the
lions at three and the giants at four
who could trade down with a team that
would like to cut the line in front of
miami the chargers at six the panthers
seven who knows if somebody springs up
to get justin herbert but that's a
possibility as well but i'm with you if
it all plays out with no trades and the
dolphins are using pick number five it's
going to be herbert instead of two of
which brings us to tua we talked during
pft live today about the possibility of
two of sliding out of the top ten you've
got him in your mock draft going to the
patriots at 13 who would trade up with
the 49ers into that spot where do you
ultimately think tua is gonna land and
in what spot do you think he's gonna get
picked
well
i'll say new england um but again that
is
contingent
on two very important things happening
number one bill belichick loving tua
and number two
uh two are getting into the teens in
other words two are getting past
oakland at 12. uh because you know and i
because i think if you're new england
you decide you definitely want them you
have to trade ahead
of uh
lost the las vegas raiders i'm going to
call them oakland for the next three
years
uh you have to trade ahead of las vegas
at 19
and you also have to trade ahead of
jacksonville at 20. because in my
opinion both of those teams
uh have a chance
with their second picks of the first
round
uh to take a quarterback who
is at worst mike at worst a very
intriguing but damaged prospect
yeah the raiders would be fascinating
and as chris sims says all the time
john gruden is a quarterback [ __ ]
durr
hoarder we've taught sims that the dir
should go on to the back end of the word
but uh yeah they've got marcus mariota
they've got
derek carr and that would be something
if they would emerge from the draft with
tua
and and here's the thing
the relationship between nick saban the
coach at alabama and bill belichick is
such that
whatever saban truly believes about tua
belichick will know whatever saban truly
understands about tua's health belichick
will know and if belichick makes the
move to get tua that tells us saban has
told him
he's the guy he'll be fine don't worry
about it and if belichick doesn't go get
him that doesn't mean saban has said run
away
but
it definitely means that saban didn't
say go get him everything's gonna be
perfectly fine and this is the guy you
need for the next 10 to 15 years
yeah and look
uh i
i think especially because i've heard
what nick saban is telling nfl teams
about tua
and it is highly highly complementary
and you know one of the other things
that you have to look at okay you have
to not only look at what your team
doctors say
about the health and welfare of tua
you also have to look at
tua the competitive person who has
played with injuries in the past
because he wants it so much and again a
lot of players really want it and are
not all that talented tua really wants
it and he's immensely talented
um and so in my opinion i think you also
have to weigh
how aggressive
this guy is going to be in coming back
from whatever ails him at the end mike
you were going to pick tuatanga veloa
and you are not going to know
if he's going to be your quarterback for
the next 10 years
that's a little bit of a worrying
thought
i just think the upside is worth it
and as to what saban is telling teams
and look i don't want to accuse the guy
not telling the truth but he is the guy
who said i'm not going to be the alabama
coach
i think he's got to praise tua he's
doesn't he i mean the guy delivered a
national championship the guy has been a
great quarterback you want to be able to
praise and hype your guys
if anybody's getting the truth though
it's bill belichick whatever he tells us
bellatrix when they get together and
hang out that's what you take to the
bank yeah
yeah yeah all right jordan
number four go ahead
the last thing i just one last thing
about this the last thing i think that's
very very important is that there aren't
a lot of people who can do things like
this in football bill belichick would
make a move like that shrug his
shoulders and say i think it's going to
work out if it doesn't we're still going
to win
yeah i mean that's the attitude when you
have the six championships you can make
that move and you don't have to worry
about getting fired if it doesn't work
out because you ain't getting fired
you're going to stay in new england as
long as you want to jordan love the next
quarterback on the list where do you see
him going
man i am
i'm clueless really uh if if i had to
guess i'd pick in the middle of the
second round to pittsburgh but it's just
a guess mike i i don't have a great i
don't have a great feel for jordan love
uh and there have to be people who have
fallen in love with love i just don't
know who they are i asked every person
over the weekend when i was doing my
mock draft where do you have love where
do you have love he's not going to the
saints i don't think he's going to the
patriots i don't i mean you know i asked
everybody who had even some sort of need
short or long term i couldn't find
anybody so we'll see
well and this could be a situation where
one of the teams that maybe would be
looking at herbert in the top ten
that doesn't get herbert
swings back into the bottom of round one
whether it's the chargers whether it's
the panthers somebody i don't think
you're gonna have to
well well but but you know what you
control them for five years that's the
one reason to do it uh and you don't
have to worry about that that 18 hours
to 21 hours between the end of round one
and the top of round two where you get
leap frogged and you lose him you know
court the quarterback position
is so critical to the success of a team
and you know we saw what happened in
2011 when there was no off season
because of the lockout there was a
run-on quarterbacks that shouldn't have
been drafted where they were jake locker
at eight blaine gabbard at 10 christian
ponder at 12. once that quarterback chum
is in the water i feel like teams throw
aside their draft board and they just
get desperate to go out and get a
quarterback who's going to reshape the
franchise for the next 10 years or so
but who knows jalen hurts is the last
one we'll talk about the guy who was at
alabama got benched for tua ended up in
oklahoma
uh where do you think he ultimately ends
up and in what round
i think he's gonna get picked in the
second round uh and and and i think
there are a number of teams mike that
are interested in him atlanta might be
interested at 48 baltimore at 55 i think
it's going to take a progressive team
that likes to do different things
on offense and what i mean by this is
you don't only do
uh you know take drew brees out for a
couple snaps and put in taste some hill
you also put taysom hill in at a you
know as a wing back or a tight end or as
a wide receiver
and you just you have him play football
and i think you very well could see a
team
take jalen hurts and want to do the
exact same thing with him have him be
your backup quarterback but also have
him be on the field 10 or 12 snaps a
game
being a weapon on offense
to basically terrorize a defensive
coordinator every week before you play
that team i i you know what i'm going to
guess atlanta at 48
that that that's going to be the team to
take jalen hurts
hey i think any team that has been on
the wrong side of taysom hill and we saw
the falcons thanksgiving night on the
wrong side of taysom hill you have to
think about what you can do
with that guy who can take a snap or two
at quarterback from time to time who can
do all those other things who can just
create mismatches and help you gain
yards and score points in unconventional
ways and when you see what the saints
have been able to do with hill you're
going to have other coaches who want to
show the world they can do the same
thing and you have to give them the
right talent last year the ravens were
toying with the idea of doing something
like that with trace mcsorley and who
knows maybe by 2020 they'll be at the
point where he can do things like that
for them but jalen hurts i like the idea
of putting him in that category and and
putting him on a team that has seen
what happens when the offense is
diversified with a player who can really
come in and and just make you afraid of
what he's going to do every time the
ball is in his hands or close to it
yeah and i think the one other thing to
think about when you think about jalen
hurts you know look what happened to the
baltimore ravens last year you know they
didn't want to play some of their guys
in week 17. you know their playoff
position was solid so they they benched
five or six of their starters including
lamar jackson you know this is the time
to basically say
you know when we bench a quarterback for
a game which we may do if this guy is a
little bit iffy health-wise
let's put jalen hurts in there you think
he's gonna have any fear of facing the
pittsburgh steelers
he's faced down the pittsburgh steelers
of college football for a couple of
years and i'm not i'm not
trying to make him cocky i'm just saying
that he's going to go in and give you a
chance to win any game you play
yeah i like it and i like the
conversation and we'll have answers to
all these questions between thursday
night and friday night because some of
these guys may last until round two so
we won't know their destination until
the second day of the draft peter great
stuff as always we'll be back on
wednesday with more pft live and also
more pftot check us out around the clock
at profootballtalk.com have a great day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports